[Música]
porque las mujeres de toda ucrania
afrontan la amenaza de la violencia
sexual como un arma de guerra mientras
salen a la luz las pruebas de ello en
las zonas retomadas por las fuerzas
ucranianas la ong human right watch ha
recogido denuncias sobre abusos contra
civiles a manos de las tropas rusas e
incluye la violación la magnitud de la
violencia sexual es bien difícil de
estimar pero entre todos los terribles
testimonios recogidos por los
investigadores hay agresiones sexuales a
punta de pistola violaciones masivas e
incluso violaciones cometidas delante de
los niños delante de los menores de edad
las violaciones y también las agresiones
sexuales se consideran crímenes de
guerra y van en contra del derecho
internacional humanitario tanto el
fiscal general de ucrania como también
el tribunal penal internacional ha
declarado que van a abrir
investigaciones sobre estas denuncias
pero la posibilidad de que se haga
justicia lamentablemente es muy lejana y
para ello entonces quiero saludar en
este momento nuestra segunda invitada
del día y es macarena
directora ejecutiva de la división de
derechos de mujeres de human rigth watch
graciasmacarena por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 para
tratar un tema que la verdad entristece
y es ella bien bien crudo como se define
entonces un crimen de violencia sexual
bueno depende mucho de en el contexto de
guerra lamentablemente históricamente en
la violencia sexual ha sido una de las
cosas más prevalentes de la guerra al
prep manera inmemorial lo que es más
lamentable todavía es que hasta
incluso entrado en el siglo 21 no había
un reconocimiento expreso de la
violencia sexual como un instrumento de
guerra específicamente el derecho
internacional humanitario que regula la
guerra si desde las convenciones de
ginebra ha señalado que cualquier tipo
de amenazas contra la población civil o
incluso la violación si son un crimen de
guerra y que pueden ser por lo tanto
quienes quienes son los que ejecutan
estas acciones si pueden ser
responsables de un crimen de hierro pero
además de eso la posibilidad de entender
la violación sexual como un instrumento
de guerra es una cuestión más bien nueva
lamentablemente a pesar de la
prevalencia de lo que significa entonces
tenemos distintos modelos no uno puede
ser el crimen de oportunidad que es como
es normal es el que más se conoce y es
cuando soldados de una de los campos que
están en conflicto
entran en una comunidad y dentro de los
delitos que cometen contra la población
civil todos ellos delitos que son
contrarios a las convenciones de ginebra
y el derecho internacional de la guerra
cometen en todas las relaciones sexuales
y otros tipos de violencia sexual tienen
que ver con usar la violencia sexual por
ejemplo violaciones masivas con como un
instrumento de guerra y es cuando ya
entonces la línea de mando dice esto es
lo que nosotros vamos a hacer y puede
ser como con fines por ejemplo de
limpieza étnica y por lo tanto la
violencia sexual puede llegar a ser un
instrumento de genocidio o puede ser un
crimen de lesa humanidad también claro
macarena cuáles son los tipos de
violencia sexual digamos aterrizando
todo esto al conflicto que estamos
viendo ahorita en ucrania
mira hasta ahora y el problema con la
violencia sexual es que toma también
mucho tiempo poder determinar dado el
tipo de violencia que se trata no que
también genera mucho estigma es muy
complicado para las mujeres denunciar
entonces por lo que presiona resuelta
documentaba hasta ahora es que
efectivamente se ha sabido de casos de
violencia sexual y de violación sexual
pero hasta ahora parecen ser más
crímenes de oportunidad que instrumentos
masivos de utilización de la guerra no
se descarta que después en el futuro se
pueda determinar que había una línea de
mando pero hasta ahora lo que se puede
documentar lo que ha podido documentarse
en el reich mart es que las violaciones
sexuales que han ocurrido que como digo
también son
delitos de que van en contra del derecho
internacional de la guerra son crímenes
de oportunidad donde un soldado varios
soldados que ingresan a un lugar donde
hay una población civil y entonces
utilizando su el ejercicio de poder que
tienen
o cometen violencia sexual en contra de
una o más mujeres y niñas claro digamos
que pues hasta ahora lo documentado se
trataría de casos aislados sino de un
instrumento de guerra como lo estábamos
conversando no macarena
claro se no significa que no sean
crímenes de guerra sin duda que son
crímenes de guerra si es que las
violaciones que han ocurrido dentro del
contexto de la guerra son crímenes de
guerra lo que no podemos todavía
documentar es que haya habido
violaciones masivas que se han utilizado
como un instrumento de guerra donde hay
una instrucción con un comando con una
autoridad hacia abajo de utilizar la
violación sexual para amedrentar a las
poblaciones por ejemplo en general como
decimos algún tipo de limpieza étnica
por ejemplo o
contra un determinado grupo de población
religiosa por ejemplo eso todavía no
podemos decir que haya ocurrido claro
macarena le quería preguntar traspasar
las víctimas por esta violación por esa
situación realmente pues lamentable y
rechazable de todos los sentidos qué
tipo de ayuda necesita estas víctimas
para tratar de alguna manera de
recuperarse y de seguir adelante con sus
vidas
mirando más lo que es una de las cosas
muy tremendas que ocurre con esto es que
es muy importante que los estados
entiendan la necesidad de entregar
emergencia de salud inmediata lo antes
posible a las mujeres que han sufrido
violencia sexual y eso significa no
solamente apoyo
psicosocial psicológico sin duda pero
también anticoncepción de emergencia
acceso a la interrupción de los
embarazos
tratamientos de posibles
enfermedades de transmisión sexual
es muy importante tener acceso a esos
servicios y obviamente que en contextos
de guerra o de conflicto armado acceso a
la salud es una cosa bastante complicada
y que por lo tanto tener la mentalidad
de que cualquier de que la atención
primaria exige en tener la violencia
sexual como uno de los momentos
elementos importantes para considerar
como los primeros elementos de atención
de emergencia es muy muy importante
lamentable y triste macarena porque
además estas personas que son víctimas
de esta violencia sexual además de todo
el trauma que conlleva una guerra tienen
que tener otra cruz encima digamos con
lo que es una agresión sexual